москвичі що живуть у хрущовках прийшли за
6 ти своєю палицею
мер Москви за пропан його президенту
Росії законопроект визнається не
хрущовок то ви справи не азам ліпідного я
будемо листя запитану процедуру you
проект уже пройшов у поєднанні у джумі
людям про куну в темряву та нижче claw тему
школа крутити каченя реву гамбургер з
темно згоден парюсь та я борюся за свою
владність і сама ви малюєте
і я км і нижче ти ніхто не моє право
вийшов цей рахунок лиману краще
кори запити до свого родіона містера
політичну дев'ятку справлятися та
партії чи людям поясні плани у
ряду
місцевих жителів заповнюють що їхню
думку вр [ __ ] проте боготу хто
зловите ти що влада просто хоче
винні ти ростиш моточка дорогої землі
я почуваюсь жахлива річ я по чому
яся ж хлибів досконалим я захищу я
зовсім не захищені
тобто це тема їжі на житло
і до я купила назарова трохи простіше на
зароблені мною я взяла іпотеку
виплатила крутіші банки і ми не просто
страшно і я зараз ну мені просто страшно
глада зараз поважаєш містер одеських
ручкою настав вік, що закон затвердіти
проект для якщо не будемо або розбір
знайти у вас і приватних масштабах така
масштабна програма жодного разу з чим життя
вкрай на тут мало такого масштабного
проекту це дійсно правдиво
лаки проект і акчурин куди успішним а я
вірю в люди зможе проїхати і в navi
квартири cs правді буде нова кисть ж
справді буде нова якість життя
для дачі поважають що ідея закону
пусте за них ручного кукурудзу б
мер Москви Сергій собянина твердіючи
собою 100 президент путін раз пробував
трьома то пак і глухим на президентських
виборах чи виборах мера у 2018 ротен
вчиш мені вдалося цей 100 точний список
буде вольпе dns і не суди для кору
підкоряється страшно боротьба за око
four третю
добровільно даємо